Better make that
dentist appointment,
because it's only going
to get worse and not just
for your gums.
Anticipation of pain
can be a major source
of anxiety for people who
deal with it routinely.
It's also probably
the reason you
haven't been to the dentist
in, oh, three years.
And a new study sheds
light on how dread of pain
can be worse than the
actual pain itself.
We know based on prior
research that the fear of pain
can produce two responses
in people of confrontation
and avoidance, although
most people probably
exhibit some
combination of the two.
Psychosocial factors
are big in shaping
in how you respond to pain.
Experiences you've
had in the past
will determine how
you deal with it.
But that avoidance
strategy-- i.e.,
not making that
dentist appointment--
can have consequences
beyond cavities.
It can result in a phenomena
called exaggerated pain
perception.
But even newer
research has shown
that when faced with
inevitable pain,
most people will choose
to get it out of the way
as quickly as possible and would
even accept worse pain quickly
rather than having
to wait for it.
A group of
researchers in England
measured this by offering
people real painful stimuli--
electric shocks-- along with
choices on how to receive it.
And what they found is
that the unpleasantness
of the dread of pain is actually
worse than the pain itself
and, even further,
that the dread can
get worse the
longer it's delayed.
Does this ring true with you?
Do you tend to work through
pain and ignore it or prefer
to chill out and rest?
Let us know your story on
Twitter or Facebook at DNews.
Thanks for watching.
See you next time.